Ezard rants is a segment where take a
less structured and humorous approach to
look at any topic that crosses my mind
relating to the subject of anime and
manga it contains my raw biased opinion
and is for the purpose of creating the
bait and/or discussion show shouldn't be
taken too seriously got that great now
shut up and listen if you count yourself
as an anime fan or even if you don't I'm
sure it's common knowledge that anime
itself is a very obscure and niche hobby
especially if you live in the West as a
longtime avid anime fan I wasn't always
the most open with my love for anime and
to an extent I'm still not not because I
feel ashamed for liking anime but
because as it stands not many people in
my real life actually have much interest
in it and nor do most people for that
matter to put things in perspective
according to Google Trends something
like attack on Titan which has taken the
anime world by storm is only just
reaching the same amount of interest
that one piece has held this entire time
and this is just a small fraction that
that super popular show like The Walking
Dead achieves when it's airing while
many people know of anime those who
actually indulge in it are few and far
between but as someone who always tries
to promote anime and gets as many people
into it as possible I always keep coming
back to one question does anime as a
medium ever stand a chance of becoming
mainstream here in the West well yes and
no it's a pretty simple question but not
as simple to answer as many my first
thing and to do so would draw from a lot
of elements from all my previous rounds
but let's start by addressing the
biggest issue it has that will stop it
from ever being knowledge by the masses
animation is simply not widely accepted
medium I can tell a mature story why
would that matter well let's look at it
this way if we look at the most popular
and critically acclaimed shows coming
out of the state you'd see that nearly
all of them are garnered towards a
mature audience the Breaking Bad the
Walking Dead's the Game of Thrones
Dexter's the Mad Men all these shows are
far from child-friendly and for anime to
ever stand a chance of being at large I
believe that it's this huge untapped
audience here that will do it
the problem is that to the Western
audience any piece of animation is
simply not an option to tell a mature
story being simply shackled to the word
cartoon given the options of either a
children's show or an adult comedy it's
a shame because when I look at my
critically acclaimed anime I don't just
see its potential compared to other
anime I see phase zero as our answer the
Game of Thrones Barker no comparable to
Quentin Tarantino movies high school the
dead as a response to the walking okay
but seriously
anime is proving us
time and time again that it can tell a
mature story and has arguably some of
the best examples of mature animation
out there but in all honesty also has
its own childish image to contend with
over here all this roots back to the
time of the anime boom in the early
2000s the time when Pokemon ruled the
world girls were looking up to their
sailor moons and guys getting hyped on
that Dragon Ball Z's the closest anime
ever comes being mainstream is normally
through a four kids dub of a children's
show or through a popular shown in which
only further cements the childish image
that is given vote let's not forget the
other quite big image that it has to
deal with anime is weird yes it is weird
even among some of the more toned-down
stories we know anime has it's still
buried between a mountain zone my blob
otaku pandering shows coming out every
season and the stuff that would raise
eyebrows if you've even tried to
describe the plot of them sure this is
part of the reason we love it but it's
even worse for the public eye because to
them that's all that seemingly out there
all they see when I look at anime is a
click of odd unsociable nerds watching
some bizarre high school girl fetish
show complete would perverse
masturbation material was a plot that's
pretty much impossible to understand the
public image for anime isn't the
greatest and it's pretty much the same
image that hardcore gamers or Star Trek
fans have to deal with in the past and
for animate to stand any chance of
becoming mainstream it needs to break
out of this preconception the public
hazards and to be honest I'm not sure if
it can yet unless we get super lucky and
had something like attack on Titan air
on HBO or wolf children get super
popular in theaters we need to look at
anime as a whole as much as we would
like to think that there are anime for
all ages honestly it's not as mature as
we make it out to be yes the image of
cartoons is highly inaccurate for the
diverse medium for anime years but in
terms of primary demographic it's still
mostly for teenagers it's a rarity for
anime to not be set in high school or
have high school aged characters for
their protagonists fanservice as I
pointed out in my previous rant is more
glorified and plentiful than it ever was
and the genre that is by far the most
popular is still the shown in genre even
in terms of movies there isn't really
anything that can match a top critique
lame stuff that Hollywood offers unless
it just falls back to the
family-friendly disney-esque
type films which doesn't really change
any preconceptions about animation as a
medium of storytelling as it stands
animes
just not mature enough yet to break out
with pre-existing image of the general
populace there's still too much reliance
on stories that revolve around high
school gratuitous fanservice in
abundance
much love animate that could appeal to
the mature audience and one attack on
Titan isn't going to change the mass
opinion alone anime simply is not ready
yet
though that's not to say that it never
will be recently there have been
snippets of news here and data hinted a
possible feature for anime over here the
highly successful little witch academia
Kickstarter campaign which managed to
completely obliterated Kickstarter goals
within days despite the fact that it did
so poorly in Japan they have to
cancelled live events due to low ticket
sales this follows news of a live-action
adaptation for now Keira sours monster
coming to HBO along with the tsunami
revival that so far has pretty much
exceeded all expectations Hollywood it
seems is also slowly starting to take
interest after producing the highly
animate influenced Pacific Rim who knows
it's Hank domestically alongside rumors
of Leonardo DiCaprio turning down a role
in a new Star Wars to work in a Robotech
movie with Tobey Maguire and Warner
Brothers announcing a new live-action
Death Note movie the prospects for
increased awareness of anime are
certainly looking up but this actually
leads me to my final question do we as a
fan base actually want
anime to become popular in mainstream
there's not already in my own personal
opinion since I never would have started
this YouTube channel if anime was more
popular and I had friends to talk about
it with but just think about it for a
second imagine a place where people
stand around water coolers discussing
their newest events an attack on Titan
where you can walk down the street with
the Madoka Magica t-shirt without having
to explain that it's a dark and edgy
show where fox news are debating the
controversial violence portrayed in elf
and leave the effect of making something
mainstream may seem like a simple case
of more popularity equals more money
equals better stuff but things don't
always work out like that if we look at
another part of nerd culture that's
become mainstream gaming we see that the
popularity spike didn't mean that
independent artists were allowed more
creative freedom to do what they wanted
but instead we now see the control of
selected multi billion mega corporations
funding the same gritty realistic war
shooters every year fits within their
business models while arguably the
majority of the creative stuff is coming
from the little guys sure there are
still some great stuff coming out but
what kind of change with anime see if it
words become popular right now we are a
cult a niche fanbase within an already
niche part of geek culture and while
there are plenty of plus sites of
finding out
our strange little hobby has suddenly
exploded in popularity and is now
understood by the masses we would lose
the uniqueness we shared when this was
just some obscure little thing that was
only appreciated by other people like
you
yes it's filled with strange archetypes
and tropes that puts other people off
but it's these characteristics that we
all love about anime as much as I
complain by the cliches and tropes of
anime sometimes if I stay away from it
for too long I secretly crave it
I want my syndra's my insane Shonen
power-ups my short high school skirts
and one it may be great for the medium
we love to be acknowledged by the masses
is it worth it at a cost of watering
down these characteristics that drew us
to the medium in the first place would
it change a lot from the thing that we
know and love at this moment and what
the fan base are in our change from the
people in this little corner of geekdom
we're all connected with so I'm asking
you guys now do you want anime to become
mainstream leave a comment or video
response for your chance get featured in
my next ramp anyway that's it for me now
though so with your response to my last
rants what do you think about fanservice
in anime fanservice
a topic it makes many people anime fans
groan and disgust as they rant and rave
about how degrading it is to anime not
to mention women in general and how is
the most evil thing in the entire world
which must be hey guys dig up here now
you may notice some somewhere different
today and well that's cuz I'm on holiday
in Thailand why am I in Thailand well
cuz um I'm Asian and die yeah if you
enjoyed this runs well be sure to check
out my other runs and a featured video
for some more interesting disgusting
videos and as always you can find your
Facebook and Twitter in the description
below anyway that's it for me now though
so I'm still waiting on my voice actors
for a verage for pi know so if that'll
be us later
but until then I've been gig up and I'll
see you all next time